thank et but with an old man and a robot
and less bicycle chases robot and Frank
stars Frank Langella Susan Sarandon
James Marsden Liv Tyler and a little
robot dude who is awesome and kind of
thing with Frank Langella robot and
Frank how did I not make that connection
that's his actual name in real life
that's weird man this movies about an
older man who's suffering from some form
early Alzheimer's possibly dementia he's
having a hard time remembering certain
things he's waking up disoriented and
his son james marsden decides knowing
I'm gonna buy him a robot to keep him
busy at home because he lives alone now
and this isn't a futuristic world where
robots are more accepted by society
there are still some people who are like
activists against robots and that's Liv
Tyler's character Frank Langella is
daughter and of course at first he's all
opposed to the idea he doesn't want to
have any friends he doesn't have anyone
around you doesn't want to talk to
things until he realizes that this robot
isn't entirely programmed to follow the
law as soon as he realizes that he's
like I kind of like this robot Frank
Langella man he was good in this movie
he was excellent because it was like
every day his character could be in a
different spot due to his mental state
he would wake up maybe not remembering
his son and need to be reminded of that
quickly and he is such a good job at
acting those scenes it was so realistic
you know he just looked so much like a
guy who's literally just remembering his
life all of a sudden they're really the
heart of this movie is the relationship
between him and this robot and it's so
funny it really is hilarious there were
quite a bit of laugh-out-loud moments in
this movie I was very surprised how
funny it was because I didn't watch any
trailers going into this movie and I was
really impressed with the humorous
aspects it's actually it's pretty
hilarious and it was like a strange
hybrid of short-circuit and et like all
thrown into one it was just it was
really entertaining the movie also has a
romance story between Frank Langella and
Susan Sarandon she's this librarian that
he constantly sees her he is nervous
about it he's like a little boy really
and it's kind of cool to see that it's
just neat to see older men in movies
basically having the same fears that all
people do because it never really
changes and this movie really portrays
that really well and it was cool to see
him figure out all the little ways that
he could get through things with this
robot maybe if I say something like this
then the robot will let me do it like he
actually started to need the robots
permission to do
things and I thought that was really
funny also without spoiling anything
this movie has a lot of plot points that
are hidden that really surprised me like
I was actually blown away there was one
part of this movie weren't where my
mouth to drop like I was like I really
honestly did not expect that at all
really really good job the movie does
have one problem though for me and what
that is is the relationship between
Frank and the robot is so funny and just
so humorous but that's really the best
emotion portrayed by this relationship
in this movie so when certain things
happen that are supposed to make you
feel like wow that was deep and that was
a big moment I felt like the movie
didn't really earn it and those emotions
felt really forced because for the most
part for me this whole relationship was
just really funny it didn't really feel
that dramatic to me at certain parts of
the movie I was like I'm not really
feeling this emotion now and that was
really my biggest problem with the movie
and it took it down a notch for me funny
is just the biggest emotion you feel out
of that relationship it needed more
heart basically but still I had a lot of
fun with robot Frank it was really well
acted it was a sweet movie great great
performance by Frank Langella I'm gonna
give robot and Frank a B+ thanks a lot
for watching guys if you liked this then
you can click right here and get stuck
man eyes